4 millions d'euros pour soutenir car
matt le ministre bruno le maire s'est
déplacé en personne à bois d'arcy pour
annoncer la nouvelle à cette société
yvelinois spécialisée dans la conception
de coeur artificiel
cette enveloppe fait partie du plan
d'investissement france relance
c'est un coeur artificiel qui va
permettre de sauver des dizaines de
milliers de vies dans les années à venir
et qui va répondre à une demande
médicale réel je rappelle qu'il ya
besoin aujourd'hui de 100000 greffe
chaque année en europe et qu'on dispose
à peu près de 3 à 4000 greffon
uniquement donc il faut industrialiser
le processus se fixer de nouveaux
objectifs
cette aide va notamment permettre à
l'entreprise présente dans les yvelines
depuis 2008 de s'agrandir avec à la clé
de nouveaux emplois sur ses sites de
bois d'arcy de vélizy villacoublay
à terme ce montant aidera la production
de 350 coeur produits par an dès 2023
une dynamique engagée ces dernières
semaines faut que les médecins
comprennent quel est le type de patients
qui rien pour le mieux quand on commence
c'est toujours ciblé le bon patient
c'est ça la difficulté c'est la raison
pour laquelle les premiers mois ça prend
un peu plus de temps mais une fois que
le médecin a compris qu'elle est patient
qui peut bénéficier le plus de la
thérapie après ça va très vite on a fait
naples il ya deux trois semaines
l'allemagne ce week end ont maintenant
ça va avancer relativement vite
bien sûr au total 22 personnes ont été
traitées par carmat depuis la création
de l'entreprise